[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Please join me in
welcoming Rob Ritchie and Krist
Novocelic.
[APPLAUSE]
KRIST NOVOCELIC: Thank you.
How did I get involved in
election reform coming out
of the music industry
and music scene?
And it was through music.
I got politically involved
in Washington state.
Bands like Pearl Jam, Nirvana,
Alice in Chains, Soundgarden
were just taking the world
by storm in 1992, 1991.
And at the same time, the
Washington state legislature
had this censorship bill.
It was really bad.
And the city of Seattle had
this teen dance ordinance.
So if you were an adult
between the ages of 18 and 20,
you couldn't go see Mudhoney
play the Central Tavern because
of the rules.
And so Seattle music was being
celebrated internationally.
But here in our own backyard,
we were getting repressed.
And so I got involved with other
people in the music community.
And we were proactive about,
hey, this is a good thing,
and you should really
foster and encourage it.
And we started to turn
things around where
music's now celebrated in
Seattle and Washington state.
But it wasn't easy.
One of the things,
personally, was, that's
how I got my civic education.
Like, how does a bill work?
You know "I'm Just a Bill."
Remember the little
cartoon or whatever, which
has a cool bass line on it.
And not just civics,
but the whole process--
like, all right, the
bill, and you're a law.
But there's all these interests
that work legislation--
the music community,
beer distributors, fans,
record stores, and
people coming together
and just engaging the system.
And there was a
lot of enthusiasm.
Like, hey, we're going
to have a concert.
Are you going to come down?
Absolutely.
I want to be part
of the concert,
because it's an event
for our political goals--
like a benefit concert.
And then, are you going to
come to the public hearing?
Yeah.
We're going to be there.
We're going to testify
for better laws.
And then, are you going to vote?
It's like, no, not really.
Like, why not?
And it's just like,
well, I just don't
feel like my vote matters.
And part of that
education was really,
like, it kind of doesn't
really matter, does it?
Because we have this
representative here in Seattle.
She's great.
But if there's, like,
100% turnout for her,
does it really matter?
Because she's going
to win anyway.
And then this other person who's
against us, he's really bad,
and he's out to get us.
But he's in a safe seat, Krist.
I don't think you can really
do anything about him.
It's like, really?
What do you mean safe seat?
Well, this is how it
works, and this and that.
Jesus, there's got to be
a better system than that.
It's, yeah, well, you know.
So at the time--
this was about 1995--
I'm on the internet.
I think I had 110 version--
two 56Ks they put together--
ISDN line or something
like that it was called.
Do you remember that?
Anyway, so I was faster than
all my neighbors and anything.
And I was on a search
engine called AltaVista.
And then I'd plug in keywords--
election reform, voting
reform, elections,
voting in the United States.
And this one group
would come up--
FairVote, FairVote,
FairVote, the Center
for Voting and Democracy.
I'm like, well,
that's interesting.
And who's their chairman?
John B. Anderson.
Oh, I remember him.
He ran for president in
1980 as an independent.
And he had this iconic campaign.
He was running neck and
neck with the Democrat
and Republicans that summer
in 1980 in the campaign.
It was really disruptive.
He went-- what's the
word I'm looking for--
viral.
He went viral.
He caught all this imagination.
ROB RITCHIE: "Doonesbury."
KRIST NOVOCELIC: What's that?
ROB RITCHIE:
"Doonesbury" liked him.
KRIST NOVOCELIC:
So it's just like,
well, he's independent.
Well, I come from the
independent music scene.
So then FairVote has these,
what is ranked choice voting?
You know, in instant
runoff voting,
you rank these candidates--
proportional representation
for the United States.
We can do that in America?
They call it the
alternative vote,
this ranked choice voting.
I'm like, oh, well, alternative
music is what I come out of.
So it was all kind
of interesting.
And so I looked into it
and I became fascinated.
Because it just seemed
so cutting edge and so
transformative.
And with Nirvana and the music
scene that we came out of,
it seemed like most rock music
was really lame in the 1980s--
this kind of predictable
'70s rehash into the '80s.
And so we came out of this
music scene that kind of
revolutionized the whole thing.
And so there was this
whole new wave of music
that came in-- grunge rock,
alternative, or whatever.
And so it seemed like
the same sensibility.
Well, how do we do with our
elections and voting-- like,
maybe we can have this new kind
of wave of democracy take over?
And again, doing
those word searches--
it was just like, well, we have
proportional representation
in the United States?
Wow.
Isn't that like how
they vote in Europe?
And it's like, no.
It's kind of like it.
Because it's not
winner-take-all.
It's not where you have one
district where everybody votes
and whoever gets the
most votes represents
100% of the district.
With proportional
representation,
you have multi winners.
And it's not a
winner-take-all system.
So you can have, say, a
district with three people
who represent everybody.
So it's like a slice of a pie.
Everybody gets their share
of the vote-- like one third,
one third, one third.
But in Europe-- wow.
In Europe, they
vote for parties.
They don't even vote for people.
Is that really a good idea?
Maybe.
I don't know.
In Europe, it
takes, like, 2%, 3%,
4% of the vote to get elected.
I don't know if that
would be very popular here
in the United States.
So looking into the
FairVote website,
reading scholarly
papers, and it's
like, there's American versions
of proportional representation.
So they're candidate-based.
So you vote for the person.
You don't vote for a party.
The thresholds to get
elected are a lot higher.
And there's versions that are
used to this day in the United
States.
100 municipalities
in the United States
use some version of
proportional representation.
And it could take 33% of
the vote to get elected,
or 25%, or 20%, or 15%.
But it's a lot higher
than, say, in Israel.
They just raised
it up to-- what--
3 and 1/2%, 4%,
something like that.
So there's these
American versions
of proportional representation.
And I thought that would
be very transformative.
Like, wow, you feel like
your vote would matter.
You could be you could be,
like, a Democrat in a rural area
and you could actually vote
for and elect somebody.
I'm an Independent, by the way.
But where I live, Democrats,
they pull in about 43%
of the vote on the coast
of Washington state.
And they elect nobody.
And then the Republican, she
wins every couple of years
automatically.
And then the Democrats
don't put any money--
the Democratic leader
here in San Francisco,
she doesn't put any of
those millions of dollars
that they collect selling
access to the Congress--
they don't put any money--
they just wrote that off.
Those Democrats
are orphan voters.
But then on the other hand,
you have Democrats in Seattle.
And it was the same thing.
It's just like,
if you have 100%--
they have, like, 70%
turnout for Democrats there.
And there's all
these surplus votes.
And it doesn't really add up.
And then there's
Republicans in Seattle.
They get nothing.
But we're all taxpayers.
We're all subject to the
rules and laws of the land.
And so somehow, there's
this current system--
this winner-take-all system
with single-member districts.
It decides who the
winners and losers are.
We have an
independent commission
to draw districts
in Washington state.
And it's just like they decide
who the winners and losers are.
It's not even an
independent commission.
It's a bipartisan commission,
where they the Democrats
and Republicans
collude, and they say,
you're going to be the
winner, and you're going
to be the loser to the voters.
In California, you
have a commission now.
The first time you
used it was in 2011.
And that was way better--
way better-- than
what you had before.
But then wasn't a DOS
system better than--
I don't know.
What was before
that-- punch cards?
You know what I mean?
You following me?
So there's this commission--
like, you've got an
independent commission.
We took it out of the
hands of politicians,
and we gave the
choice for voters to--
the commission decides
who wins and who loses.
So proportional representation
is, we decide who votes.
So that's how I got--
I just felt it's just
a way better system.
And so people aren't
really like plugged into--
I guess it's really
new to a lot of people.
But I got involved
with FairVote.
And so we work a lot with
the Voting Rights Act.
And here in Santa
Clara, there's going
to be an initiative
on the ballot
to change to proportional
representation
as a remedy to the
Voting Rights Act.
And a lot of people will
assume that the Voting Rights
Act doesn't say anything about
having these this district
elections as being the remedy.
And actually, that's
where you find
proportional representation
in the case law in the United
States.
It's coming out of
the Voting Rights Act.
Because it gives
minorities a voice.
So it facilitates
minority representation.
It's just that simple.
So if you're a
political minority--
say, a Republican in
this Democratic town--
you could possibly elect
somebody on your council.
You're a racial minority.
Absolutely you can
elect somebody,
if the people of that race
are like-minded enough
to elect somebody.
But it doesn't assume that.
When you put districts together
with the district elections,
that assumes that people
are going to be like,
well, you're Latino and
you're going to vote Democrat,
or you're black,
and you're going
to vote Democrat, which is fine.
But the proportional
representation
doesn't necessarily
make that assumption.
It lets the voters decide.
And so that's basically
my stake in this,
and why I'm such a
forceful advocate for it.
Because we're taxpayers.
We're subject to the rules
and the laws of the land.
And we should
decide who we elect.
Instead, we have
political insiders--
the same people who sell
access to Sacramento or Olympia
or Salem or whatever
the statehouse,
or the US Congress--
today's boss-- those are the
people who are also making
decisions on the
most fundamental part
of our democracy--
the interface between the
citizen and government.
And they're saying,
here is this system.
It's the winner-take-all,
single-member system.
And this is how it works.
We draw these districts,
and then you vote.
And then we make sure that this
district is safe for Democrats.
We make sure that
this district's
safe for Republicans.
And maybe there's a few
toss-up districts in between.
And I think we can do a lot
better than that, especially
in the 21st century.
Everybody's really concerned
about gerrymandering.
And if you want a solution
for gerrymandering,
absolutely, let's have
independent commissions.
But that's just
part of the deal.
Voters need to have
a say, ultimately,
on who represents us.
And that's what proportional
representation is.
There are American
versions of it.
They're constitutionally
protected.
They've been scrutinized
by the courts.
And they're in use
in the United States.
It's that simple.
How am I on time here?
12:20.
So I guess we can move on.
ROB RITCHIE: OK.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: And then we'll
do the Q&A so you can really
kind of give it to me.
ROB RITCHIE: All right.
Hey, thanks, Krist.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB RITCHIE: So,
great to be here.
Thanks, Martin,
wherever you are.
Oh, there you are--
Marcus-- right next to me-- and
the Bright Spots collection,
which has been exciting for us.
I have been doing
this for a long time.
Every year, I think
progress has been
made in a way that felt
good in our year-end letter
to supporters.
But certainly, in the
last few few years,
things took off in a
certain kind of way.
We got a big statewide
win that I'll talk about
for ranked choice voting.
We quintupled our members
in the last 18 months.
And we've got people like from
the Bright Spots collective
and others--
Bain Capital-- a collection of
people and some lawyers saying,
how can we help?
And people are trying
to do things, too.
And it's a climate which I think
speaks to some kind of people's
concerns about the
specific outcome of 2016
and how it happened,
but, I think, also,
just this climate of feeling
that our democracy is really
in a state of crisis.
Stepping back from
the point about how
we can change our systems
from winner-take-all
to a proportional
system, we need to.
We're in a sort
of state of crisis
that I think is in a cycle
that isn't going to get better
without intervention.
And that's why I said
we want to walk through,
and then why we think ranked
choice voting specifically
is a wedge into that--
not the only one.
There's a lot of
other great work
being done-- but
one that we think
is fundamentally important.
So getting back to
first principles,
the vote is this quietly
radical concept, right?
It hasn't been part
of human history.
I mean, I'm sure people voted
in certain family groups
and so on.
But deciding the
consent of the governed
and letting people
cast an equal vote
based on just being
a human being,
it's a pretty radical concept.
And of course,
because of that has
been people who are
worried about it,
and those who are in power not
necessarily embracing the power
that, essentially, they're
turning over to people.
And some of the rules that
have developed over time
have been quite intentionally
kind of crafted in ways
that I think minimize
or miniaturize
the power of our vote.
Some are just that, when we
started voting, the technology
and the understanding of what
options we had was different.
And a country like
the United States,
which has been
around for a while,
wasn't aware of
some of the options.
And Krist talked about
some of these uses
of proportional systems
down at the local level.
But higher up, we've
settled into kind
of institutional inertia
and a false belief
that it's always been that
way, or it has to be that way,
or that James Madison wrote in
stone that, thou shalt do it
this way, which is
actually not true at all.
The US Constitution is a
blank slate about voting.
And it's actually
something that we
are designed to really be doing
creative and innovative things
in states and having it go up.
And yet, we get this sort
of stalled political class
that, in fact, has an interest
in keeping it the way it is.
People don't know
much about options.
They're sort of distracted
by other things.
And we muddle along.
And the US economy
works and things.
But at a certain
point, actually,
the policymakers really matter,
and government really matters.
And right now, it's in a
mode of deep challenges.
And I think this work is
monumentally important.
Two ways that the vote
is sort of transparently
restricted in ways that we're
going to get into today--
one is we get to
indicate one preference.
Most of our elections, you get
to just vote for one person,
right?
That's it.
And so if you have
two choices, and you
get to vote for one of
them, you have magnificently
indicated a preference
that sort of fully says,
I like this person more
than the other person.
And you add up the votes, and
one person gets more of them,
and then you have a
winner, unless you're
using the electoral college.
But if you have more
than two people,
you're only voting for one,
and you've said nothing
about the other two.
If you have five
people, you vote for one
and you're not saying
about the other four.
You're starting to
actually not allow
people to indicate
preferences that,
in fact, might be quite
significant and important
to know.
And we can.
It's just a simple
matter of asking voters
to reveal opinions they have,
and then using that information
to actually get better outcomes.
And that's really the idea
of ranked choice voting.
And we'll get into
that in a moment.
And then the second
major restriction
is one that Krist
was getting into,
which is that we are accepting
this sort of geographic tyranny
that where you live determines
your representation,
and everyone who lives
in a particular place
should have one
representative, even if they
have very different views.
And we don't really organize
ourselves necessarily
by geography in the way we
think and the way we certainly
think about politics
and the way we
might want to organize ourselves
and put forth a representative.
But we have one person per area.
And that's a major restriction
that, as Krist was saying,
51% represents 100%.
And imagine an
economic environment
where the only way
you can make money
is if you're the actual biggest,
and if you have a new idea,
you don't get any reward
for it until you're actually
the biggest in the industry.
That would be sort of
stifling for what's possible.
And that's the restriction
of the single-member district
system.
Neither of these are
in the Constitution.
All of these can be changed.
And all of them
actually have a lot
of history of being worked on.
So for expanding
preferences, the model
that we've settled on--
and I think for good reason--
is ranked choice voting.
When we talked at the
start, some people
seemed to know
something about it.
But who knows something
about instant runoff voting
and ranked choice voting--
just a show of hands.
So in this system, rather
than just vote for one person,
if you've got this
multi-candidate situation,
you get to say, oh,
here's my first choice.
But OK, there's these
other candidates.
Here's my second choice.
And here's my third choice.
Santa Fe, New Mexico, just used
ranked choice voting for mayor
for the first time on Tuesday.
They had five candidates run.
And they had this very sort of
respectful, substantive, civil
campaign.
Voters went in and,
overwhelmingly,
ranked a lot of the candidates--
first choice, second
choice, third choice.
And the reason that they
had gotten interested
in this system is, they'd
had a whole string of mayors
who didn't win more
than half of the votes.
So when you have
multiple candidates,
when you add up all the votes,
someone might have 39% or 32%
or whatever it might be.
And there's a belief--
and rightly so-- that the
person who's winning just
happens to be at the top
of the heap, but, in fact,
could lose one-on-one to
someone else, and, in fact,
isn't the one who really
would have won if only
those two people had run.
So the idea of a
ranked choice system
is to use that added
information to determine
who is really the most
representative candidate.
And we see this work a lot.
Like the Oscars just
picks Best Picture
with ranked choice voting.
The biggest conservative
party in Canada
is using ranked choice
voting right now
to pick their leader in
the most populous province.
And they did it last
year nationally.
Same in the country of
New Zealand last week.
We're seeing a lot of
uses of this system.
It sort of works.
And it works psychologically.
Because, one, people
often have preferences.
If you go into an ice cream
store and you want chocolate
and they don't have
it, you usually
know what else to ask for.
And then you get it and
you can feel someone happy
even though you don't
get your chocolate.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: Strawberry.
ROB RITCHIE: Strawberry?
Vanilla bean.
And the logic of the
system kind of makes sense.
So you just drop
the last person out.
So you add up all
those first choices.
And if you've got someone who
has a majority in this system,
you're done.
Because you're just trying
to get a majority winner,
which is more than half.
If you don't, the candidate
in last place loses.
You look at their ballots.
Those people have
indicated preferences.
You add them to each
voter's next choice.
You see if you get
a majority winner.
You keep going until you
get a majority winner.
It makes sense in a lot of
the elections that we have.
So the 2016 presidential race--
the general election had two
major candidates, but then
some interesting
other candidates.
Like Gary Johnson was
the Libertarian nominee.
Jill Stein was the
Green Party nominee.
There were some
other people as well.
And actually, most of
the big swing states
were not one with a majority,
like Michigan and Wisconsin
and so on.
And so in those states,
if we'd had this system,
we'd have said, OK,
it's not over yet,
because the people who
voted for Stein and Johnson
and others could have indicated
a second or third choice.
And you look at those
ballots and then you
add them to whoever
is next, and you
would have an instant runoff.
You would have had this
head-to-head comparison.
And this whole
poisonous climate of,
oh, why are these third
parties running, goes away.
And you actually might get
a more legitimate outcome
that people can
say is acceptable.
It's interesting.
There's been a lot of talk
about the Russian hacking that
happened.
And yeah, we're hearing a
lot about that, obviously.
It doesn't seem
like they actually
hacked into any machines.
But they hacked our
plurality system.
We absolutely know
they did that,
because they did all
these sort of Facebook ads
to promote third party
candidates and try to disrupt.
Our system is vulnerable to
a certain kind of activity
because it's not a
very good system,
so that they could drive
certain people to vote
for a minor party candidate.
They knew that that wouldn't
help the minor party
candidate win, and it
might change the outcome
of a major party race.
ranked choice
voting would kind of
deal with at least
that kind of hacking.
But it does a lot
more to it as well.
So back in Santa Fe, it's
sort of interesting history
of a city that has a
lot of local politics
that get pretty
negative and poisonous.
And it's got kind of
an interesting angle--
a white divide and longer-term
Santa Feans and newcomers.
And there's some
tensions and things.
This was a fascinating campaign
for all the people you talk to.
They had the most
debates they'd ever had,
and respectful, civil debates.
So why might that be?
If you sort of think about the
system, if I'm trying to win,
and I'm pretty darn sure I'm
not going to get more than half
of first choices,
I know I'm going
to need to be some
people's second choices--
the backers of other people.
That means two things.
I need to learn about
what other candidates are
saying to kind of understand how
I can appeal to their voters.
And I just am going to
talk to more people.
I mean, the thing you
hear over and over,
particularly at that
level, is, you're
walking through a
neighborhood, and there's
a yard sign for someone else.
And in the old system,
you walk by it and say,
I'm not going to
waste my time there.
With ranked choice voting, you
go in and you have a dialogue,
and you hope to be
their second choice.
And who knows?
You might persuade them
to be a first choice.
So there's sort of an
extension of the dialogue.
And so when the
winner comes in, you
can't guarantee someone's
going to be a good mayor.
But this person has
a lot of tools now.
Because actually, the guy
who one went from 39% to 66%
during the count
at the final round,
meaning that he really did learn
about a lot of other people.
He really was good at getting
second or third choice.
He has a lot more to work with.
And let's see what he does.
But a system can
actually really change
the rewards of how to be
a good representative.
And, I think,
fundamentally, we're
at a point in our politics
where the politics of two
and the limitations of that
are increasingly disconnected
from how we think
about the world
and how, particularly, I
think younger people think
about choices.
And you know, I grew up
where there were still
three networks and PBS and UHF.
And that was it or
something like that.
But now, my kids
don't think that way.
And yet, in politics,
we're sort of
supposed to be
satisfied with that,
even though we know it's
not delivering, actually,
particularly good
choices, and it's
creating incentives
to act in ways that,
in fact, aren't very good.
And it's just a matter
of a statutory change
that we can do.
Any state can change how we vote
for president, US Senate, US
House on down on their own.
In the state of Maine--
is there any Mainers here?
Probably not.
But Maine is going to use
ranked choice voting in June
for all their big primaries.
And they're also going to
vote on keeping ranked choice
voting, which we
think they will.
And if they do, then they'll use
it for US Senate and US House
in November.
They didn't actually try
to pass it for president.
That's a future thing
that they can do.
But they could've.
But the way our system
works, actually, states
have a lot of leeway to kind
of lead in Democratic practice.
And that's been our
sort of whole history.
We started with incredible
limits on suffrage.
And many states didn't vote
for president and so on.
And then we keep
learning and expanding,
and states pushing the
edge of the envelope.
Women's suffrage didn't
kind of magically
start with a
constitutional amendment.
It started with states using
it and cities using it.
And that's what we're seeing
with ranked choice voting.
And I think it's,
I believe, kind
of an inevitable
conversation for us to have.
Because I think
that binary choice
is just not going to
work going forward.
And the restlessness that
the voters are going to feel
is going to create more and
more tensions with the system.
And it doesn't mean that
the major parties are bad.
It just means that they
need to be accountable.
And they can't just be
there because they're there.
And they can't use
the rules and tools
that they have to keep
themselves entrenched,
which is essentially what
we've allowed to happen.
We allow the major parties,
in their campaigns,
to run as political actors.
And then they win,
and then they're
legislators making
policy determining
the rules of the game
that, then, they run in.
It's sort of an
intrinsic problem
to just kind of turn that over.
And when we think of
politics being broken,
it really, in a
sense, is actually
working just as you
might imagine it would
if you let that happen.
And I think that we really
can't keep letting that happen.
So I think Krist touched
well on the part of what
it means to go from a
single-member districts
to a multi-member district.
But I'll use a specific example.
This other sort of fundamental
way that our vote I think
is limited is, when we
vote for the US House,
we vote in single-member
districts by statute.
Actually, that's a
congressional statute
from the 1960s, where
they required every state
to use single-member districts.
And we had states at
that time that didn't.
And in a sense, we
were saying every state
that has more than one seat
needs to draw districts.
And once you start
drawing districts,
it's usually sort of a
self-interested process.
But even when it's not,
like in California, just
geographically, you have
partisan imbalances.
We don't redraw state lines.
Maybe we should, but we don't.
And so we all know
which states are red
and which states are blue
and which states are swing.
And it's actually
very entrenched.
And there's fewer swing
states than there used to be.
And counties-- we don't
redraw county lines.
The average county was
won by 15% in 1996.
It was won by more than 40% in
the presidential race in 2016.
The median county was won
by more than 70 to 30.
So you put a bunch
of counties together,
and you do not have a
competitive district.
I'm sorry.
And so it's super
easy to know who's
going to win almost more than
90% of congressional races.
And if you live in one
of those, binary choice,
stuck on one side,
your interest,
maybe, in the 2018
election is, how can I
channel money and volunteer
time in that Nevada
3, or some other
particular district--
probably not where you live?
There's a bill in Congress.
Ro Khanna is actually one of the
sponsors of it, the congressman
from around here.
And it would be to,
by statute, actually
take the logic of the
1960s bill, which required
single-member districts,
and, instead, require
multi-member districts
with ranked choice voting.
When you use ranked
choice voting
in a multi-member district,
you get those virtues
of the ranked choice system
as used in Maine and Santa
Fe and such places,
but you also can expand
who gets to help elect someone.
Because each seat can be won
with a smaller share of votes.
And then collectively,
almost everyone
gets to help elect someone.
So you really expand that
kind of voter power that way,
which is why it's such a good
tool for the Voting Rights Act.
So this isn't just
theoretical for us.
And I think that it's
this time of opportunity.
I've been doing
this for a while.
But I think this
moment of disruption
which we're experiencing in
our politics in multiple ways--
and it's not just
about Donald Trump.
It's about, like, there's
a series of things
that, our politics
isn't working,
that really are sort of
deeply troubling to more
and more people.
And again, I don't think
it's self-correcting.
There's a really good
paper that I wanted
to draw people's attention to.
Michael Porter, this Harvard
Business School icon,
wrote it with Katherine Gehl.
It's called "Why Competition
in the Political Industry
is Failing America."
It really lays out where
we are, I think, very well.
I don't agree with a lot of
the prescriptions they have.
But I do like that ranked
choice voting is among them.
But essentially, they lay
out the challenges we face
and the fact that we do have
the power to change things.
And I think if we
don't, things are not
going to get better magically.
I think some of
the deep divisions
we have that combine
with winner-take-all
are highly problematic.
And we're in a cycle where this
kind of change has to happen.
And I think all of the other
changes in our society too--
the Me Too movement
is partly about women
having a seat at the table.
There's five women governors.
80% of Congress-- four out
of five-- are men still.
For Republicans, it's
more than nine out of 10.
And at a certain point,
that's just not going to work.
And how can we kind of
unloose this system?
And actually, one of
the outcomes of the Fair
Representation Act would
be a very likely rapid rise
in the number of
women who are winning,
a fluid way for our racial
and ethnic diversity.
Is anyone from Santa Clara?
Just curious.
So Santa Clara is
voting on ranked choice
voting the multi-member style,
and ranked choice voting
for mayor in June.
But there's a whole bunch
of cities in California
that are addressing the
fact that they're not
very representative in
their local governments.
Santa Clara has an
all white city council
in a city that's
majority minority.
And you're seeing that
in a lot of places.
And the push is to have them
go to single-member districts--
go from at-large
elections, where
they get to vote
city-wide, and then vote
in each single-member district.
But we don't necessarily
live that way.
We don't necessarily live
in our little pockets
of racial difference.
And there's some things that,
maybe, a single-member district
does.
But it doesn't necessarily
allow you to kind of fluidly
determine your own
representation every election.
And that's a really
important conversation
we should be having.
And California's
actually just doing this
without the conversation
really happening much.
But Santa Clara
is going to allow
us to have that conversation.
So we're really excited
about that campaign.
We're also seeing, I think,
a realization that it
can work at a higher level.
So this Maine situation
was interesting.
I don't know how many of you
have heard of Paul LePage.
He's the governor of Maine--
pretty controversial guy.
He brags that he was Donald
Trump before Donald Trump was.
But he's part of a whole
string of governors
who didn't win half the votes--
in fact, didn't win even 40%
of the votes when they won.
The last three
governors of Maine
all won with less than 40.
So it's a state that's ahead
of the curve, as far as
having independents and third
parties doing pretty well.
And it creates this tension
of split votes and spoilers
and people saying, you shouldn't
vote for the third party
candidate.
But people are still
doing it and sort
of controversial outcomes.
And Maine responded to that by
passing ranked choice voting
in 2016 with the second highest
vote total that ever had been
passed in a ballot measure.
And then speaking of the
challenges of changing things,
we've had to deal with
legal issues or election
administration challenges.
And I won't go into
the whole story,
but they basically repealed
it last fall, finally,
in this brinksmanship that one
of the parties was playing.
But in Maine, you
can do a referendum.
You can actually say, no,
let's not accept that law.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: Before
it was even used.
ROB RITCHIE: Yeah.
So they've collected
the signatures
to force a referendum
in June on it.
So they're going to vote in
June on whether to keep it.
And while they're
doing that, they're
going to get to vote with it
in these races for governor,
where they've got 10
Democrats running and five
Republicans running.
And those people will run
with ranked choice voting.
So that has the potential to
be a really big breakthrough.
And we're seeing more states
where that can happen.
Just yesterday, the radical
bastion of Utah just passed
ranked choice voting
as a city option,
with a really
explicit understanding
that they want to try
it out at a city level
to see if it's ready to work
in Utah at a higher level.
And it's just fun
to see this moving
in different ways
in different places,
and more and more groups getting
involved, and more and more
state groups forming.
And I think we're entering
this different phase.
One thing I just wanted to
highlight as a possibility--
we'll see what happens--
but the 2020 presidential
race is looming.
And almost certainly,
we'll again
have some third party
and independent energy.
We'll see.
Who knows on which side?
John Kasich is
saying that maybe he
won't run as a-- who
knows what he'll do?
But he sort of said it's time
for a multi-party system.
Does he run on that
side of the spectrum?
Do we see kind of a Bernie
Sanders force run on the left?
We'll have to see.
But our politics is
in this tense mode.
And some states could
use ranked choice voting.
So we're going to elevate
the goal of trying
to do that at least
in a couple of states
to show that that's possible.
And then the
presidential primaries
will be really interesting.
The Republicans had a
lot of people running.
And I think that part of what
Donald Trump was able to do
was dominate the media cycle and
kind of be the plurality guy.
And actually, all of his
wins up until really late
in the process were by
plurality, not by majority.
And if he'd had
to win majorities
earlier, who knows how
that might have affected
how he campaigned and
maybe, ultimately,
how he governs today?
But Democrats face that
same dynamic in 2020.
Is it just a race to 25%?
And what does that mean
for the way you behave
and the way you try to
bring people together?
And you can change those rules.
Like, Iowa caucuses could
change that simple party rule.
It's very straightforward to
change ranked choice voting.
So we're going to try to
look into that idea, too.
And the Fair
Representation Act is not
going to pass this Congress.
But it does have
several co-sponsors.
And I think when you're having
dialogues about gerrymandering
and about, wouldn't it be great
if we had a competitive race
where we live, or, wouldn't
it be great if we had more
diversity of representation,
or, I'm a Republican in the Bay
Area, or, I'm a
Democrat in Oklahoma,
or, I'm a pro-life Democrat,
or whatever it might be--
a pro-choice Republican--
there should be more
space for more of us.
And we have a system
that really makes it hard
for these different
perspectives to be elected
and realize that that's an
answer just sitting there
that we can keep
building support for.
And we have some ideas
about how that might happen.
But Santa Clara's a place
where that can start.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: Want to do Q&A?
ROB RITCHIE: Yeah.
So let me just finish, before
we do that, with two things
that I wanted to do.
So one is to talk about the
ways that people can help.
So one is that there are
these efforts going on.
And there's lots
of growing numbers
of state groups for people
who are interested in donating
to things.
There there's lots
of ways to help them,
including the
Santa Clara effort.
But also, we have been
intrigued by the way
that people have
stepped forward to help.
So Louis is part
of a group that has
taken on a frustrating
challenge that has really
been a barrier to us over the
years, which is that ranked
choice voting has often
made sense to policymakers
in particular settings,
and then they turn
and they find out that their
voting equipment can't do it.
The whole way we vote--
what we vote on--
I mean, it's funny, when
you're on a place like Google
where you're so far ahead of
the curve on doing things.
And the way we vote is just
pathetically antiquated
and poorly administered,
including most
of the counties around here.
San Francisco and Oakland use
these more than decade-old
systems that would
essentially be
like using the phones
we had 15 years ago
and saying, like, that's cool.
That's really cutting edge.
And it really limits
what we can do.
We actually have four
cities in the Bay Area
using ranked choice voting.
But they do it in
this awkward way,
tied to the voting equipment.
That's San Francisco, Oakland,
Berkeley, and San Francisco.
And they stepped
forward and have
been working with
some folks that we
knew to create a
universal tabulator to be
able to work with
legacy voting equipment
and, essentially,
make it much easier
for some state like
Missouri or something, that
gets interested in
ranked choice voting,
to be able to work
with this widget--
it's more complicated
than that--
to be able to have a
federally approved,
tested, certified system to be
able, in a secure way, to use
ranked choice voting on
the older voting equipment,
aggregate data from
different systems,
and get past that puzzle.
The next round of
new machines are
going to get better
and better on this.
And it's certainly
not rocket science.
But it's been
incredibly helpful,
and will almost
certainly open the door
toward more things going on.
We have a tool--
RankIt.Vote.
I was going to show it to
you, but I'll just tell it.
RankIt.Vote is a way to just
vote with ranked choice voting
and create a quick poll and
share it with your friends
and so on.
But you know, I would imagine
Google Vote or something
right--
just sort of a great
interface where
you where you could go in,
maybe choose your voting system.
There's other
voting systems, too.
We could get into that.
But there's other ways
to a vote-- but something
where people can make a quick
decision about something.
Or an organization could do it.
60 colleges and universities--
even more now-- use
ranked choice voting,
all figuring out how to do it.
And if they had a nice
tool to securely run
ranked choice voting elections,
that would be terrific.
The last thing I'll say is,
we have this tool, Monopoly
Politics, where we
project outcomes
in congressional
races, and then show
what would happen if the
two-party were, like,
53% to 47%.
What might that do for outcomes?
And you can put that number in.
And it's a pretty good Excel
tool that we're showing online,
that kind of shows
it, which, by the way,
shows-- if you put 53% in
right now, for the Democrats,
you don't get a Democratic
majority in the House.
And you can sort of see why, and
which districts don't change.
But we'd love to make something
like that really inviting
to play with.
So there's lots
of ways that we'd
love to kind of work
with people too.
And let's turn it to questions.
SPEAKER: All right.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
We're going to go to questions.
There is a Dory.
This comes from Darryl Gove.
Why not approval voting?
Ranked choice voting seems like
cognitive overhead for voters
and complexity for counters.
Approval seems easier and
should bias towards candidates
with broad appeal.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: We're here
to talk about ranked choice
voting.
You can read all about approval
voting on the internet.
I mean, we're here to talk
about ranked choice voting.
Ranked choice voting
is in the law books.
It's used internationally.
It's used in the United States.
Let's do the next question.
ROB RITCHIE: Yeah, no,
I will just briefly
mention that, Krist, just
because it's interesting topic.
We're in a room of people that
think about technology and not
being tied to what's been done.
ranked choice voting has been
done much, much more than
some of the other alternative
systems that are kind of
interesting to look at,
like score voting and
star voting and approval
voting, Condorcet voting.
There's these sort of different
ideas that are out there.
And I think they all
speak to certain virtues.
One of the things
that's interesting,
though-- sort of the
challenge-- is, a lot of them
are sort of mathematically,
technically sound,
but sort of psychologically not.
And let me just give a quick
example of approval voting,
which is why I think
it is used so little
in competitive elections.
If you think about, say, that
Republican presidential field
in 2016, with approval,
you would say,
oh, I like this person.
I like this person.
And that's it.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: Approval voting
is, you get all the candidates,
and you can vote for every
one of them if you want.
Fill in the 0.
Just boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom.
SPEAKER: It's like [INAUDIBLE].
ROB RITCHIE: Yeah.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: Yeah.
ROB RITCHIE: So yeah.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: It's just
like, that's what it is.
It's--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROB RITCHIE: So
it's like if you're
doing a doodle something.
But here's the thing.
When you're actually in
the heat of the fray,
it's really hard for candidates
to say, yeah, go ahead vote
for my opponent with an
equally cast vote that
might make me lose, and
for voters to actually get
in that frame, too.
So it's psychologically
not as sound as the math.
But we're also going to
say, hey, give it a try.
It has very little
use in practice.
And ranked choice
voting, we know, works.
That's what I think
Krist was saying.
We know it works.
We know that voters actually
do it, and you want a system--
KRIST NOVOCELIC: It's been
scrutinized by the courts.
ROB RITCHIE: --that
actually does it.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: And so if
you want to advocate a voting
system, you're going to come
across a lot of opponents
in the establishment.
And the insiders
don't want change.
And the first thing they do
is, they run to the lawbooks.
And they're going to sue you.
And so with ranked
choice voting,
it's been scrutinized
by the courts.
It's constitutionally protected.
ROB RITCHIE: And we actually
hope more places try out
more systems.
But I think we're
pretty confident that
ranked choice voting's ready
to go to the highest level
right now.
SPEAKER: What are your thoughts
on Lawrence Lessig's as person,
one vote Equal Votes project.
Will the lawsuits they're
bringing to the Supreme Court
help in your mission?
ROB RITCHIE: Do people
know Lawrence Lessig?
Kind of interesting guy.
He did a lot of stuff
on internet freedom
and was at Stanford.
Now, he's at Harvard.
He's done some
interesting stuff.
We're actually
going to be, likely,
working with him on some
stuff on our particular goals.
One of things he's
trying to do is
take on the electoral
college as it currently
is done in the winner-take-all
rule, which is another statute.
It's not in the
Constitution or anything.
So when candidates
win a state, they
get all the electoral votes
in that by winner-take-all.
So if you win by 20%, you
get all the electoral votes.
If you win by one vote, you
And his lawsuit is
against that principle.
We'll see.
I think it's going to be
a challenging legal theory
to go deep into the courts.
But I welcome the dialogue.
We actually are not fans of
the electoral college system
as it's currently
constituted, and think
that having a dialogue
about it is good.
AUDIENCE: So I guess I
sort of have two questions.
The main one is, do we actually
have data on how many people
rank more than one
candidate when they do
ranked choice voting,
or do a lot of them
just still put one person in?
And if they aren't putting
in a second person,
is it because of
lack of education
about the other candidates?
Is there a way to
encourage people?
Because that would be the
biggest thing I would think
would happen.
People would be like, I don't
know who these people are,
and they just
wouldn't even bother.
ROB RITCHIE: Right.
Well, it's an
interesting question.
So the more interested
they are in the race,
the more they'll rank everybody.
So just as an
example, we did a poll
in the Republican
presidential field
at the time of the Iowa caucuses
of real, likely Republican
voters.
It was an online
poll with YouGov--
so a pretty nice
sort of way to be
able to show your preferences.
Did not say rank everybody, but
it offered them the chance to.
And more than 90%
ranked them all.
KRIST NOVOCELIC: How many people
ranked in Santa Fe last week?
ROB RITCHIE: And
Santa Fe-- exactly.
We don't actually have
the full data yet.
But Santa Fe, first
time use of it--
one is, they're getting
better ballot designs.
Do some of you vote in
San Francisco or Oakland?
So they have ranked
choice voting.
In the mayor's race,
a majority of people
use all the rankings
allowed, which is three.
A majority of people
will do that for mayor.
They're not allowed
to do more than three
in the current ballot design.
And then if it's like a lower
level board of supervisors
race, a majority will
definitely rank more than one,
but not as many.
And so the less you know
about the candidates,
the more you won't do it.
But in the Santa Fe
race-- so five candidates.
It went all the way
through down to two.
When they got to the final
round, of all the people
that voted in the
first round, 96%
had made a preference
between the final two.
It was kind of cool.
And you know, it's a
pretty diverse city
with a lot of differences.
But people had learned
about the candidates
and wanted to
indicate a preference.
The other part of it is that,
now, you have candidates who--
you're saying like, oh, I don't
know who these candidates are.
The candidates know
you might think that.
They have a reason
to engage with you.
So what you're
starting to see is,
people are starting to get
the playbook of how to win
with ranked choice voting.
And the playbook is, talk
to more people, which
is actually kind
of a good thing,
particularly at the local level.
So Minneapolis and St. Paul
or places like that are using
ranked choice voting.
And you're just seeing deeper
levels of conversations going.
SPEAKER: What are
the biggest obstacles
to getting ranked choice
voting to be more prevalent?
Do you see a lot of
opposition from the main two
political parties?
KRIST NOVOCELIC: You can.
There's opposition,
because you bring change.
And there's a survival
instinct of, say,
a politician or a
lawmaker to say, well,
how's this going to
affect my election?
And you saw it in, say, the
presidential debates in 2016.
It's just like,
why didn't we have
more people up there
instead of the Republican
and the Democrat?
Because they didn't want
to have any competition.
And so things are
so polarized now.
It's like people are just
afraid of the other side.
And they're so afraid.
Or they demonize the other side.
They don't have the
mental bandwidth,
the cognitive ability
to just say, well,
maybe I should go for this
independent or another voice.
Because they're
afraid that they're
going to help the other side.
And so the wagons are
circled on both sides.
And so with ranked choice
voting, it's very powerful.
It's just like, you
have your first choice.
It's your strongest choice.
I really, really like her.
And I'm going to make
her my first choice.
But you know, she's all right.
I'm comfortable with making
her my second choice.
But that second choice is not
hurting your first choice.
It's a sophisticated way
of ranking your candidates.
And people are so
polarized now in the tribal
with the Republicans
and the Democrats.
And it just seems like
whatever the issues
are running in the news--
and then why don't you just
look at your own election
system in California?
They just changed the rules.
You're going to have your
primary election in March.
So all the candidates run
for whatever state office
in March, or Congress,
or for US Senate.
And then the top two
candidates, no matter
if someone has a
majority or not,
they run again in November.
That's, like, almost a
whole year of just getting
stuck with two candidates
I mean, why did the
legislature do that?
That's a big deal.
In France, they have
runoff elections.
In France, they have an
election for their assembly.
If someone wins a majority in
that district, they're elected.
If there's no majority, they
have a runoff two weeks later--
two weeks.
And here, it's just months.
And then behind the scenes,
you have all these insiders.
I'm answering this question--
who's against it?
Not just the political parties,
which are soft money conduits.
They sell access to the
legislature to Congress.
Then they raise
millions of dollars.
And then these bosses dole it
out to who could win or lose.
There's also these other groups
that work behind the scenes,
and voters have no
idea who they are.
And they're chamber of commerce
or unions or identity politics
groups or some issue groups
on the left and right.
And they're doing
independent expenditures.
They're spending
millions of dollars.
And they don't want
to change that power
to give voters power.
Why would they
want to give voters
power when they have the power?
When you're stuck with two
choices from March to November,
that's what they want.
Because if you had more
choices, you'd have more power.
If you have more power,
then they have less power.
So that's why
they're threatened.
A lot of them are threatened.
There's rational, good
government folks in Sacramento
and on the local level
and in the Congress
that recognize
the value of this.
But there's also a lot of
people who don't want it,
because they don't want
to give up their power.
ROB RITCHIE: Yeah.
And I'll say, just to
add as a tag to that,
there's sort of an
insider versus outsider.
It's not left versus right.
But it's often like a
younger versus older.
Some of our most
passionate people--
the guy we were
working with in Utah--
conservative Republican.
He's, like, 29.
And he's just, like,
really into it.
And the guy in Georgia who's
really into it is, like, 26.
And they don't to be that
young to be really leading
that effort.
But they tend to be
to be more ready.
In 2008, when McCain and
Obama ran against each other,
they had both been prime
sponsors or prime advocates
of ranked choice voting.
They were sort of
a little bit of--
not outsiders, but
kind of change agents.
And so you will see people like
that who are more like that.
And you know, the
current DNC chair likes
ranked choice voting.
A guy from the second
Republican race
a few years ago is one
of our key advocates.
So there are interesting
changes happening.
And there is resistance.
But I think a lot of those
folks recognize it's not
working that well either.
And they can see that this
is a way to let it breathe.
I'll just say about
top two and the point
that Krist is making--
so you all live in the
top two environment,
which has some
interesting aspects to it.
So I don't want to be
just critical of it.
But a part of it
that's challenging
is, you only get
to vote for one.
And so in those primaries,
the first round,
you only get about for one.
So Republicans are worried they
might not get someone advancing
to the general election.
And that's because there's more
than one Republican running.
If only one Republican
ran for governor,
they're pretty much a done
deal that they get in.
But it's a split vote.
And Democrats are worried
they might not actually
get any in races
that they otherwise
could win in the
congressional level,
because they have too
many people running.
And that's a product
of a system that
just doesn't allow us to say
more than we were able to.
SPEAKER: Rob and
Krist, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]